[Applaudissements]
il y a un film que j'adore que tu as
fait c'est Miss Mona ou tu faisais le
tram un film de medichard
pour le faire il a fallu qu'il s'y mette
à plusieurs pour te le faire faire
c'est-à-dire que quand on vous
quand quelqu'un vous téléphone en vous
disant j'ai déposé un scénario dans ta
boîte à lettres Lilo très vite et je lis
un scénario qui s'appelait Miss Mona et
je trouve
ce sujet formidable je trouve le
scénario je dis ça très rapidement parce
que c'était un scénario très très
nerveux et qui venait tout de suite en
images et puis medicharef me téléphone
le lendemain dit alors je trouve ça
formidable c'est bien de me l'avoir fait
lire pour avoir mon opinion il dit non
c'est pour que tu joues mais qu'est-ce
que tu veux que je joue dans
de ma gueule et je raccroche moi moi en
travelo c'était quand même pas moins
habillé surtout que c'était c'était pas
un travelo c'était un transsexuel
c'était donc un personnage qui devait
avoir toute sa vraisemblance habillée en
femme et puis finalement bon je suis
tombé sur des producteurs extrêmement
persuasifs ils sont venus à la maison
avec des talons Louis XV des jupes des
des perruques tout ça et j'ai commencé
j'ai senti le vent de la réussite autour
du personnage quand on m'a passé un sac
autour du bras essayez chez vous même si
vous êtes mal hein mettez-vous un sac
comme ça et vous verrez tout de suite
vous verrez sans femme que par le talent
Louis XV le sac comme ça sur
l'avant-bras vous avez l'air femme
essayez chez vous
non mais
ça c'est absolument extraordinaire et si
bien que tu as pris goût le problème
c'est à dire que je me suis retrouvé
quand même dans le bois de Boulogne
allons aux asperges
habillé en Marilyn Monroe c'est quand
même formidable et j'ai rejoué dans ce
film la fameuse scène de
la grille de la robe qui se soulève de
l'Europe absolument et ça je trouve ça
absolument formidable
dis-moi c'est vrai que les harder les
types qui font les films X c'est vrai
qu'ils sont tellement habitués à se
retenir quoi parce que ça dure longtemps
les prises etc c'est le cas de le dire
c'est vrai qu'après il ne puisse
masturbe pour qu'on voit le ce qu'on
appelle le raccord et Jacques quoi qu'on
voit vraiment le le sperme qui qui coule
c'est vrai qu'à force de se retenir il
peut plus jouir autrement qu'en se
masturbant non je crois qu'il y a c'est
pas vrai ça non je crois qu'il y a
beaucoup de choses qui sont qui sont
exagérées comme comme dans tout
d'ailleurs
remplacé comme conscience de la gauche
c'est Bruel ah bon
à la masse
pas jaloux mais c'est toujours énervant
quoi je veux dire un mec qui pulvérise
des scores à ce niveau là quoi je veux
dire c'est quand même une compétition ce
métier on a toujours envie d'être le
premier et le meilleur ou dans le groupe
de tête tu as dit qu'il avait rien à
dire j'ai dit ça moi
en politique tu dis qu'il avait rien à
dire et il était il fallait le lire il
était là un jour on t'a parlé de Laurent
Fabius et tu as dit je préfère Che
Guevara c'est toujours vrai
non mais j'avais lu un article une
gamine de 20 ans personnage que vous
préférez
c'était en Fabius l'idéal de société
quoi
et encore aujourd'hui
non c'est même pas un bon gestionnaire
d'une équipe de football de bonne équipe
de football là je veux dire apparemment
les résultats sont non c'est un mec que
j'aime pas trop quoi c'est un faiseur
c'est un balance
ces entreprises qui rachètent et tout
qui fait soi-disant fleurir en fait il
fait en fleurir en licenciant 90% les
ouvriers qui se retrouvent à la rue ou
au restaurant du coeur pourquoi tu
détestes autant les chauffeurs de taxi
j'ai déteste pas je les connais
rien rien que de temps en temps il faut
que ça sent bon de temps en temps
faudrait qu'il soit aimable de temps en
temps faut pas qu'il nous change le
tarif avec un doigt comme ça PAF
malencontreux et que tu surveilles qui
te dit non monsieur j'ai pas fait exprès
à part ça tout va bien je les aime mais
attention tu sais que il te déteste
aussi il me déteste oh merde ma fille
avait tourné un sujet qui était des
réactions de chauffeur de taxi quand on
leur montrait ton disque j'ai consulté
mon mon petit ange et mon petit diable
et on l'a pas diffusé mais ouais mais
c'est un diffusable ah bon ce que ces
mecs là disaient vis-à-vis du CSA c'est
complètement diffusé
pas tous et ceux qui disent du mal de
toi taxi qui te déteste tu leur réponds
quoi bah je leur réponds pas j'essaye de
le faire tout petit parce que générale
c'est des costauds ils sont en fait j'ai
pas envie de me prendre les 3000 volts
dans le eh oui
c'est une partie sensible à moi aussi il
y a eu plus grave quand même il y a eu
l'affaire des des insignes nazis sur les
uniformes
ce signe est un ce qui prend un signe
nazi à l'envers si tu veux c'est un
vieux sigle
de judo
mais de
d'arts martiaux c'était très très vieux
signe qui existe sur un uniforme dans un
dessin animé japonais
toute la série c'est à dire qu'elle est
séries qui passent qui sont pas
entièrement visionnées
[ __ ] merde Jacques mais viens [ __ ]
tu es en train de me [ __ ]
pourquoi tu te casses comme ça tu me
fous en l'air dans l'émission
C'est des questions c'est vraiment c'est
c'est terrible tu me connais tu sais
bien que je pose des questions copain et
puis d'un seul coup c'est c'est un piège
t'as jamais vu mes émissions non mais
pour les autres c'est différent je suis
quand même je sais pas on est sur la
même chaîne sur la même chose
mais enfin là je suis en couple
ok ouais je m'excuse
je te prie de m'excuser
je veux
je te prie non non simplement comme tu
le ferais au soir où tu rentres très
tard et où tu dis à ta femme j'ai été
retenu par la télévision c'était retenu
par la télévision excuse-moi et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de tube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu